macht ihn kaputt machen vorwärts
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute in
diesem video zum titel schon gesehen
werden wir endgültig bestimmen wer der
beste youtuber deutschland ist jetzt
diverse fotos von den besten grüßen
youtuber in deutschland vorbereitet von
den besten zeit nicht in welche firmen
mit wir haben heute eine unfassbar
fachkompetente jury die darüber
entscheiden wird welche youtuber jeweils
der bessere ist wir lassen die
gegeneinander antreten wir haben acht
youtuber bezwang im viertelfinale an
dann werden vier ausscheidung zur zeit
finden oder wenn zwei ausscheiden einem
final mit einer ausweitung eine wende
wissen wer der beste deutschland
berichtet porsche leute erste der zwei
köpfigen jury heute ja und natürlich
muss ich auf den zweiten sure heute
vorstellen das ist niemand anderes als
die hölle los alles klar jung seine
bereits erste viertelfinale verdient
haben hier einmal krank pravda okay mein
bruder und miguel pablo wer ist der
bessere schutz von dem band der müsste
schon gegeneinander machen
was macht fliegt raus wie pablo gewinnt
gegen marx damit selbst für die klage
entschieden von ihr bekommen als wir
draußen kannst du verkantet wieder genau
zerreißen zu erreichen
[Musik]
im zweiten viertelfinale ist wird an wie
beauty fälle
nachdem die achtung erst mal die beiden
[Musik]
einstimmig bbc kein stück raus ist man
plötzlich der reifen war zunächst im
viertelfinale es geht an kraft gegen
khalifa bot wer von den beiden der
bessere youtuber der ok dann müsste der
schüler schon machen als ich schon ein
ist von einiger bedeutung lässt sich
tanzverbot rauszulassen zu heißen und
luca kommt ins halbfinale
[Applaus]
damit kommen wir zum letzten
viertelfinale leute und es geht an
maskottchen gegen ich bin ich wer ist
von den beiden der bessere werbung als
bester bessere hierzu werden alle
mitbekommen dass natürlich nicht gewinne
dieses duell klar
und damit ist die masse zu erreichen das
heißt leute wir kommen zum halbfinal den
ersten heute als treten an dass die
leute jetzt sind sie da oder gefragt wer
ist der beste von den bands
[Musik]
alle machen zusammen ich mache bin ich
raus
als richtiger fan von luca ab macht ihn
kaputt ist im finale das ich gerade auch
wenn es nicht merkels finale und konnte
leider aufgegeben würde es mal zu
anstrengend für ihn deswegen mora bist
du immer noch sie trifft er und meine
schwester hinter der kamera die
zweitstimme sein und wir fangen an mit
dem zweiten und letzten halbfinale tritt
als pablo morgen schon okay ich kämpfe
mit und für die zahlung wird die listen
kannst ihr versuch meister bereits im
offiziellen brauchen es nach
cook mit den händen
alles klar damit kommen wir zum großen
finale geschafft den fähigen für mich
und du willst du eigentlich mit sich
einfach aus prinzip zu schützen
[Musik]
alles klar leute die attacke war recht
eindeutig die jury hat entschieden ich
hoffe ich habe die ganze nacht geräumt
wie ungemein karten hier oben bekommt
ihr persönlich